[Applaudissements]
j'ai pu
s'échapper
j'appelle tout de suite après la
présidente du marché tu appelles va
[ __ ] la merde
tu te casses et des amis tu te faire
[ __ ] c'est marianne la merde pour rien
la soif et rooney conçoit des petites
yukio consent dangereuse c'était un
piège
cette étape est fait canada pour moi
mais qu'elles sont la [ __ ] trois mots
que le canada va taper mais ça y est
déjà au top à paris intra muros au
canada
arrête un peu ton histoire tient pas
debout près n'importe quoi à la seule
chose que tu va animer sa concours de
bambou
je laisse un message à bryant a annoncé
la présidente du groupe nrj mais dans ma
chérie ces énergies électricité tu te
tais
[Rires]
tu sais comme nous sommes nés tous les
deux cmj la gueule du jeune le monde
doit pas de sapin des gens pourtant
mariam
je voulais te dire j'ai un gros souci
marianne apparemment
il y a des gens de chez toi qui ont
essayé de débaucher un de mes
chroniqueurs
mariam s'arrête aussi simple que ça il
est 19h 4
à 19h14 considère règles de course auto
guerre
[Applaudissements]
exactement dix minutes on me rappelait
pas une minute de plus
mariam
ce coup de pression
je te plaît s'il te plait
pas mettre canad inns jacmel tout de
suite le président du groupe m6 vidéo
nihilo ce qu' il n'est pas du tout du
tout il n'est pas du tout aux skis je
l'appelle eemeaa tia maria qui
m'envoient désolé mon cyril je suis en
réunion je n'en vois tu as dix minutes
johnny
alors maintenant je mets donc appelé le
président non mais le président a mis
les peintures s'appelle arthur cela
s'est vraiment
fait tu te tais il est peut-être
beaucoup trop quoi président il
chapeaute palais quemado
s'il vous plaît si j'avais besoin de
vous je vous rappeler avant
bras soit je l'appelle je vais l'appeler
et je vais car m6 a essayé débauche mais
chroniqueur aurait dû tout haut ce qui
est s'il vous plaît si le pays n'est pas
du tout ce qui je l'appelle je vais
l'appeler immédiatement et l'ordre à
sanaa mais
c'est un bon ami non mais vous le
connaissez bien sûr arthur d arthur d
exactement il connaissait vraiment gros
vous le connaissez vraiment ouais c'est
le président du groupe insa pfl a cru
que tu je vais l'appeler immédiatement
et je vais lui dire mes quatre vérités
ouais mais ça c'est que ce soir
notre groupe est en guerre
c'était un peu vous riche pour rien non
des gens de l'extérieur du val du mal et
ces gens
qu'on appelle les récalcitrants
dans le milieu je vais m'en occuper et
je vais m'en occuper de suite je
l'appelle immédiatement mais ils ont
tous des poils
après vous vous étonnez que personne
nous a pénalisés pour eux après les
appeler changer sa peine et tout le
monde a des problèmes
il arrête tension ouais mais tu avais
dit voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous inquiétez pas
on interdire n'avons pas tellement tuer
sa messagerie
arthur ce n'est pas la première fois que
je vais dessin message passe à pains
arthur
arthur tu sais comme toi et moi sommes y
est tu sais comme je t'apprécie
malheureusement
nous allons au devant de gros problèmes
il ya de ça quelques minutes un
chroniqueur nommé raymond se sont vrai
nom c'est cyril et son vrai vrai nom
c'est kader
avoué il ya quelques minutes car mc
avait essayé de le débaucher
j'avais promis en jurant houle
que je ne dirais pas
mais ça va trop loin alors tu rappelles
moins vite ou envoie moi un signe
un message et 19h08 nous sommes en
direct
19h18 je considère avec le groupe tout
en guerre
aulas
on a plus qu'à attendre on a plus qu'à
attendre mais vous n'êtes pas flatté
qu'on attend de lui quand d'autres
prénoms alors malade vous m'avez
récupérés dans la rue écoutez j'ai pu
qu'écouter rien dégrader physique au
mieux les pouces c'est une plaie
ordinaire je rejoue alors je vous ai
déjà très peu de jardinage
avocat me